[Music]
when i skate i feel like i'm flying in
the ice and it feels really good
[Music]
this great big story was made possible
by lego play her way
[Music]
my name is yong yu i'm 15 years old and
i'm a figure skating who represents
south korea
i was six years old when i started
figure skating and the first time when i
was in the ice it was really hard to
just stand and just skate so i fell a
lot but i still think it was really fun
young you is a three-time south korean
national figure skating champion she was
just 11 years old when she won the title
for the first time making her the
youngest in history
she also qualified for the winter
olympics in 2018
when i was 14 i qualified the olympics
but i was too young to compete the
olympics sadly
[Music]
young yu has a rigorous training
schedule which has her traveling the
globe i train in colorado and japan and
korea
i'm now working on my triple axel triple
axel is spinning in the air like during
the half rotation that is the most hard
jump into triples
after that i'm working my quad style
with the harness the quad cell is
turning near four rotations so it's the
most hard
jump that i'm doing
being a figure skating champion is hard
work but young you is motivated by the
support of her family
sometimes i'm not good as usual but my
mom supports me and giving love so it
helps me and all my families are like
cheering me up it makes me do more hard
work
[Music]
[Applause]
in the competition
when the music comes my heart is
bouncing like it's gonna burst and it
feels like i'm flying
[Music]
you